[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm dominic monaghan
and i'm billy boyce we are back in a
podcast studio
and i don't know about you bills but it
feels like things are really cooking now
i'm really cooking you know what i mean
it's like we've put it out into the
universe there was a while there where
we were kind of
screaming into the great void i mean no
one was listening no no one's listening
now i feel like what with instagram
and youtube everyone's starting to pick
up on the fact that we've got a podcast
so you
know you think people are listening yeah
is anyone watching
i think people are watching as well
right hello youtube if you guys are
listening and you want to watch you can
come watch us
at the friendship onion on youtube but
if you'd rather listen
come find us anywhere that you get your
podcasts yeah can we talk about your
body position
of what i've done here as i'm sitting
quite
uh for anyone who's just listening i'm
sitting
quite erect with my right leg across my
left
you're adopting what i like to call the
michael corleone in the godfather
position you know like when he
actually becomes the godfather yeah he
he's just sat in this very powerful
position
but even though i feel powerful when i'm
in that show
i don't think i look great like i'm a
bit insecure now well see before
when you were sitting like that you look
like to me
a big dog you know like a great dane
who sat his butt on the sofa but
doesn't really know what to do with his
legs i think i should lounge a little
bit more
that's quite nice our producer john just
told me to lean
in this direction well that's good now
you look interested
and interesting well thanks um how was
your drive
over to here yeah it was all right
actually
um i was going i was going to listen to
our podcast
right because i enjoy your podcast you
do
um but i couldn't get myself organized
and
you know the when i i plugged my my
phone
into the car the car wouldn't recognize
it
and it was getting me so annoyed so i
ended up listening to a 90s channel
so i was listening to some music from
the 1990s instead
that's one of the more irritating
moments of my life with technology
where you think i've done everything
that you've asked me to do i've turned
it on
i've linked you just because you can't
talk to this there's nothing else i can
do here i'm not in a place where i can
step in and do it yeah
and now it just becomes a very expensive
piece of plastic well here's the thing
then that you like
i went to the um i went to the car
dealership yesterday
because my trunk wouldn't open for the
last my boots
uh or trunk for the usa
and i hadn't opened for about a week
right
and i couldn't open it with the button
on the key i couldn't open it with my
hand
manually it just wouldn't open so i took
it
i made um i made an appointment early in
the morning 8
a.m i drove the car over there i said
this
this trunk will not open
and he went into the golf compartment
and there's a button there
that says valet button valet
and he pressed that he said try it now
and open file so what what's a valet
button what's all that about
apparently it's if you drop your car off
at a valet then you can press this
button
and it stops people getting into your
trunk say for instance you've left your
your diamond rings in there or something
right
how would i ever know that yeah you
wouldn't know that i was thinking there
was like an angry family of raccoons on
the inside of your trunk
holding it down enjoying the darkness
you know that was what i had in my head
before then is it not true that
a family of rats ate your car
yeah so i this is interesting because
you come full full circle with your wife
here
remember talking to your wife saying oh
you guys have gotta get a compost tea
you know we eat so much fruit and
vegetables and it's a great
place to put it and your wife said i'm a
little worried about
maybe bringing in more mice and rats to
the back of our garden i said well yeah
you will do that but there's mice and
rats everywhere yeah
my compost tea was directly opposite
the kind of front wheel base of my car
and mice and rats are relatively smart
whereby
they're going to get food from there and
then on the way back they think
well here's a warm place i don't know
it's a car
but it's nice and warm because the
batteries stay warm in a tesla for ages
and they burrowed into my car but can i
tell you bills
i think a couple of them died in there
because when you're driving your battery
gets so
hot yeah that it would probably cook a
family of mice oh
so i would turn on my air conditioner
and the smell of
cooked dead mouse would come through the
ac
unit and i got my car washed and valid
like
yeah uh and they eventually i went to
tesla and they eventually ripped it out
and they said look there's like
like a bird's nest there's like a nest
of dead mice in here
so i had to get rid of my compost tea
and it made me think
billy's wife is actually correct i
probably shouldn't have a compost heap
so close to things
that's sort of instant karma or
something isn't it
i was going to ask you because obviously
in britain yeah
me living in manchester you living in
glasgow you jump in the car every so
often but usually it's a
15 20 minute drive type thing in los
angeles we're much more accustomed to
a 45 minute drive an hour long drive has
that
changed in any way the the way that you
approach your
car because my car now is in some way
like an office
no you're absolutely right and when the
car
does connect to your phone i love
like sending texts and things not even
business but just to
like say you yeah i love you dom you're
great yeah you're great why are you so
great yeah
and then do you want to send this
message yeah i'll send that
and then i'll send maybe five six eight
messages and i think
i did something yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
a you know i'm a big fan of twofers
for the price of one so i used to love
filling up my car with petrol
or as i say in the united states gas
which is crazy because it's not gas it's
a liquid
oh yeah weird and whilst filling up my
car with petrol
cleaning the windscreen because i think
well i can't move because i'm waiting
for the car to fill up so i'm going to
get a two for the price of
one here i love that and like you said
when you're driving
if you can send a little voice message
that turns into a text you're getting
two for the price of one you know
on the drive over i'd said to you
i'm going via a coffee shop would you
like anything because you and i are fans
of coffee
you said no i'm all right i said i'm
going to get a little snack a little
breakfast maybe a
a croissant maybe a little pan or
chocolate something like that and you
said
i will not eat a savory croissant
well yeah because that's what you
offered me you said they do a lovely
croissant
with mushrooms but you love mushrooms i
love mushrooms
i love croissants but neither the two
should ever meet
but a croissant is not sweet it's not
like you're getting a sweet
cakey thing with a mushroom the savory
croissant savory well to me though
a class arm should be eaten with a
little jam
right or maybe i mean maybe a nutella
yeah i could have it with just butter
but if you're having a croissant with
butter that's basically a
heavily buttered pastry with butter on
top
dom that's heart disease i absolutely
love
butter yeah me too i'll take butter
on anything remember my beautiful mum
telling me years ago
that if she could eat anything with no
health restrictions whatsoever
it would be bread and butter and i think
i'm that way too a nice fresh bread
stick some butter on there have a nice
cup of tea oh
what could be nicer guys if you have any
buttery stories
please send in any stories concerning
butter
heavily whether it's eating butter or
using butter to maybe fix a tool
or a piece of machinery please or a sun
bun
spreading it on sunburn if you have any
questions you can also send us them
to speakpipe.com forward slash
tfo yeah now the speakpipe.com forward
slash tfo
is an answer phone service wait a minute
it's not actually tfo
it's the friendship onion oh that's
right we we're calling the show tfo now
because that's what the cool kids say
but if you want to leave a message for
us at speakpipe.com
forward slash friendship onion that
means that maybe we'll play that answer
phone message
in a upcoming episode of the podcast and
here's a little tip for you guys right
there
if you want to have a chance to be on
the show try and ask us a question that
we've not been asked before right
yeah and it doesn't have to be a lot of
rings it could be anything it could be
anything it could be a buttery question
but you know billy and i have probably
asked
what is it like to play a hobbit
you know what's peter jackson like
what's your favorite thing about new
zealand
ask us something that we might have
never been answered before and there's a
much higher chance that we'll answer
that question
nice nice tom you know what i watched
this week what was that
nomad land oh i saw that which was
did it win best picture i think it did
it did one best picture yeah i found her
really
uh kind of free in both her performance
but also as a person did you see her at
the yeah
yeah she just seems very yeah childlike
in a beautiful way
um i love that film the score was
amazing
lovely very simple and i don't know
anything about that community of people
that
you know kind of sell up their house and
drive across
the united states but the amazing thing
about the united states is it's such a
massive
landmass you could spend 30 years
driving around it and you wouldn't
get bored because from state to state
yeah it's so different
well it totally amazed me when i heard
the percentage of americans that don't
have a passport
but then when you actually think about
it
there is so much to see in the united
states of america
as it showed you in that movie that you
could easily spend your life
just looking at in different states
i love that film there's a great moment
in it where she
is kind of chatting to a young drifter
they meet at one point
she gives him a lighter and then a few
weeks later they meet again on the road
sit down and share a cigarette together
and she asks him all the questions that
i think
she's got in her head about herself
where she says you know is there no one
who loves you yeah is there no one who
misses you
is there no place that you can go back
to you should do that
it's important for you to you know go go
after that girl or go see your parents
and
their kid kind of says ah what do you
know old woman in a nice way you know
don't tell me what to do type thing
but i love that moment because i think
those questions are flying around
her head yeah beautiful film yeah and
you're quite good at looking at a film
and
and thinking oh that moment meant that
and
you know and what did you think when she
had
violent diarrhea in that bucket
i remember you telling me you you saw
the show before you saw the film before
me
and you said what a performance by
francis mcdonough it's amazing
no makeup no hair no vanity
and i said oh yeah that's impressive and
you said well not only that but she does
violent diarrhea into her bucket
but they don't cut do they i mean you
see but it sort of comes from
do you feel as though i felt like is
there a scene missing
well she ate something bad and well what
did
was there an eating thing it wasn't
really
because there's a scene with david's
stress i'd never know how to say it yeah
yeah there's a scene with him where
aren't they cooking together isn't he in
the kitchen and they're cooking or he's
cooking and she's watching but is that
not a different
i felt as though i'm i thought that came
from nowhere
but then but doesn't diarrhea
it's true diarrhea does come from
nowhere yeah that's a surprise
a lot of the time isn't it well guys if
you've seen nomad land and you want to
tell us about what you thought about the
film oh
best film of last year yeah according to
the oscars and
i might agree i thought it was brilliant
or if you've traveled around the united
states
on road trips and there's something that
you want to recommend to
billy and i because i'm sure at some
point in the future we we could take a
road trip we could take this show
on the road why not well that'd be
amazing or even if you've ever had
violent diarrhea
yeah leave us a note i have a story that
i
think i'll probably say for like episode
you know where this we'll keep that
that's episode 20 25 or 25 or something
like that where
i had a
wardrobe malfunction involving feces
at work let's just leave it at that i
feel as though you've started it now
yeah have you well i don't think we can
go into i think that's more of an easter
egg
i think you're right we'll get to a
point where we have something like a
million followers
and then i'll drop the story about
[ __ ] myself in front of a whole crew
of people
please rate review and subscribe because
when we get to a million
subscribers dom will tell this story
i'll do it
philly and dom eat the world all right
guys well listen every week
we ask you to send us in suggestions
of either a an item of food or maybe a
beverage
that from your neck of the woods is a
staple that we might not have heard
about now this is a slight cheat this
week isn't it because we have heard
about this
we have heard about it but we did want
to discuss it so on you go what are we
doing this week
well this week my friend we have
bundaberg ginger beer now
we know this because our esteemed
director and filmmaker friend peter
jackson was a massive fan
of bundaberg ginger beer wasn't he yeah
so we started drinking it in new zealand
i remember going we were invited to
pete's house quite a bit
at the weekend just to hang out or maybe
do some work and in his fridge
he would always have bundaberg and he
was a big fan he was always pushing it
it's
very sugary i don't care like butter
i don't mind some sugar i made ginger
beer with my
dad and brother when we were kids and
the amount of
sugar that you have to put into it to
feed
off the sugar to stay alive is
incredible it's quite disturbing isn't
it when you even if you make lemonade
the amount of sugar you've got to put in
there yeah can i put you off
drinking it really now this is an
australian ginger beer i think a lot of
people think it's a kiwi ginger beer
very often in a stubby little bottle
we've got them in cans today i've never
seen them in a can before me either that
was john it got us there but your friend
that are esteemed producer john but
uh friends out there australians i would
guess
who are used to that beautiful stubby
bottle
um will be a little irked that we're
drinking out of the can but still the
same taste i think let's see
sugary is that so sugary i mean we are
chemical factories at the end of the day
right we wake up in the morning
yeah and you we're basically just like
filling ourselves with different
chemicals whether that be a happiness
chemical or a sugary chemical or a
coffee yeah
do you know what i mean just for us to
work as a machine yeah
and if we can make it tasty or lovely
then all the better
i'm going to try it now tom try it
now i'm sure you guys can see out there
if you're watching on youtube
the friendship onion youtube channel
this little can right here
42 percent of your daily sugar needs
is in this can that is a lot well that
gets almost half of it done
yeah i'm not sure if you need 100 of
your sugar every day really yeah i think
sometimes you can go like 70
and it's not a big the sugar in things
you don't know though
oh super good ginger beer
was kind of invented at a time where
they were trying to
preserve the quality of the water
stop it from being compromised so they
would add
ginger and sugar into a fermentation
process thus keeping the quality
of that water drinkable that's how they
found ginger beer
and it used to have a lot of alcohol in
it right not anymore although does this
have
some alcohol in it i don't think well
trace amounts
no i don't think so because it used to
be
there was up to 11 alcohol
that's a lot of alcohol that is a lot
because like a strong beer might be kind
of six percent
yeah really strong beer i would think
but then they
they put on taxis onto beverage with
more than two percent
so people who made ginger beer said
let's cut that let's cut down the
alcohol it was always stored in stone
bottles
because it was such an ugly liquid
people didn't want to look at it was
that why was it the cloudiness
cloudiness it just didn't look like
something would want to drink it
so they would put it into a stone bottle
and even now if i see a ginger beer in a
stone bottle
i think that looks good really good and
also i think the
the bundaberg people recommend that
before you open it you're supposed to
gently
tip it up and down so that i like a
cloudy gingerbread i don't like a clear
ginger beer
i want the cla i like traditional
lemonade not a big fan of normal
lemonade
and i was astounded when i came to the
united states and found out that
lemonade over here
is flat well it's like lemon cordial in
it yeah
but lemonade for me growing up was like
sprite and 7up yeah we call it that
don't
they don't call it lemonade that's
something else no um
guys if you've never had a bundable
they're not sponsoring the show or
anything like that we just like them
because they're so tasty they're
reminders of
of new zealand but if you've never had a
bundaberg ginger beer go find them
and if there's a food item out there
that you guys love
that you want us to taste maybe it's
super tasty maybe it's a little weird
yeah you know there's some strange
tinned fish from sweden that is supposed
to be absolutely disgusting
but people in sweden love it they love
it send us it or
tell us to buy it and we'll buy it we'll
get it we'll get it
but apparently uh bundaberg
is is still a family run business
even after all these years i think it's
been around for like 60 years
i like that idea mr missy fleming oh
hello mr mrs fleming or the or the
fleming family i guess because
i love it when it's like a family thing
don't you
yeah well they say that about like
johnson and johnson they say a family
company and i always wonder what that
means
hmm i mean a family company
it just sounds nice maybe they're trying
to lull you into a false sense of
security
and they did so there we go there's
bundaberg
ginger beer we'll be back next week with
another episode of dom and billy
the world or is it billion dollars i
think it's billion yeah whatever it is
i always put you ahead of me because
you're my senior well i feel like
billy and dom do something sounds better
but
dom monahan and billy boyd sounds better
really
so i think if we're using both our names
you first
if it's just singular names me first
you sent me something the other day i
can't remember what it was i mean had
your date of birth on it and i was like
my god he was born in the 60s
it's 1967 68 that's the year that the
beatles white album came out
i remember it amazing all right we're
moving on
it's time for i will take the ring
here we are it's time for a quiz dog
it's quiz time
it's quiz time so now the rules have
slightly changed this week
because we're evolving the quiz in a way
aren't we well we're all evolving in
some way
so a good point actually so so we've got
nicholas and ruben here
and they're going to be answering
questions against each other but also
reuben you're going to be on my team dom
and nicholas all right you're going to
be on billy's team
hello nicholas if you're stuck on a
question
but it can only be one question you can
ask
your teammate to try and help you out
but we might not know the answer because
we don't know the answer so just letting
you know
sounds good let's go you might know it
so you might not need us but if you need
a port in a storm it might be one of us
all right
so who's first bills you go first you go
first
all right so am i asking do i ask
nicholas all of his questions and you
ask ruben all of his questions uh
no the opposite isn't it the opposite
yeah all right okay all right ruben here
we go here's question number one for you
all my life let's go here we go oh this
is so easy
what is the name of the ant who carries
mary and pippin through fangorn forest
is it
gray tree tree stash
robert the grape or tree beard
you know it's a tough list that you got
for me there but i'm gonna have to go
with
treebeard is the correct answer that's
one for reuben
lovely stuff for reuben and dominic nice
nice work
question two who tries to destroy the
ring
at the council of elrond
is it aragorn gimli
samwise or boromir
i'm going to have to go with gimli son
of going
no i don't know if it is i i feel like
i'm trumping that as well because
doesn't gimli try and hit it with his ex
yeah gimli tries to hit up with an axe
john so what does bori may do john
boromir just sits there and says we
can't just walk into
mordor nicholas i'm sorry about it i'm
sorry about our producer here hold on
till we check this
and laura makes some memes during the
council yeah
basically yeah
there's no need for a fact check we know
john it's skimly
i mean barami says you can't just simply
have a walk into
bar into academy
no but i thought gimli jumped up and
tried to yeah he hits it with an axe
nicholas doesn't even have an axe we've
wasted your time
moving on you're next you all are
confused is because you all are hiding
behind the bushes during that scene
exactly eating biscuits
john we're gonna we're gonna overrule
you we're going to say it's kimly sorry
it's one what oh boy one each
other we love it when our producer is
wrong right ruben here we go
question number three the return of the
king was nominated for
11 academy awards but how many did it
win
is it a 4 b
7 c 10 or d
all of the 11.
oh you're testing my knowledge i know
it's either i'm i'm stuck between
all of them or 10 but
because i know in total the trilogy 117
i do know that
wow well you know what if you're not
sure you know you can always throw one
to
dom but then that's it gone that's it
that's it um how many questions are
there total oh that's a great
question gotta gotta get that strategy i
think is the t
is the two i would say there is
five each yeah you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with 11. i
think it won all 11.
reuben it's the correct answer that's
the correction
well done and you know how you know that
reuben is because mr steven spielberg
got up on stage and he said it's a clean
sweep which means we won't ever see the
the reason i knew it is because i don't
remember an even number being on the
little dvd box that i bought
i don't remember it being a solid 10.
right you see
i really think's very mathematically
yeah good for you
i remember when steven's because we were
there at the oscars i remember steven
spielberg said
he said it's it's a clean sweep and i
looked over at billy to celebrate and
you were pouring champagne
all over you all over and i'd taken off
my top yeah
remember that beautiful lovely like an
adonis okay okay
next question which actor of the
fellowship
is the tallest in real life is it
john reese davis sean astin
billy boyd or mr dominic monahan hello
well it's a tough one if i remember
correctly the way you
had to film it meant that uh gimli had
to be taller than all the hobbits so i'm
gonna go with
john reese davies it's the correct
answer two
two that you're absolutely right so all
the hobbits were sort of the same height
and then john ruiz davis is like half a
foot taller
which means the hobbits and gimli could
act in the same
scenes without any special effects true
story
although we didn't do a massive amount
of stuff
with john reece davis because
unfortunately he was allergic
to the prosthetics that he put on his
face so he could oh
yeah he could only work every third day
so he'd work on a monday
then he'd have to have tuesday wednesday
thursday off and work on a friday it was
a scheduling
nightmare let me tell you all right
it's two each guys here we go reuben
this is a tough one
okay how old was frodo baggins
in the lord of the rings books was he
51 27
32 or my favorite number
apart from 74. 68.
so i'm gonna have to give props to my
father and this one who read me the
books
nice but from what i remember
it's been about a hundred years but i
would
say 51
is the correct answer incredible
nice unbelievable necklace
are you ready ready what
do the elves call hobbits
do they call them perianath
the perianath or the
onadrim or the urukai
or the hairy feet
i'll give you those again because it's
difficult a
the perianath the onodreme
the urokai the hairy feet
so it's gonna have to go with go with
the perry enough
yes wow
nicholas nicholas did you just pull that
out or did you know it
i uh i might have known that before dug
deep into the memory for that one
tremendous knowledge i didn't know that
didn't you i knew that i didn't know
that
all right it's what is it three three
it's three all it's very exciting
okay we're coming right down to it now
all right reuben here we go
all right question seven what is
gollum's name
for the sun is it
the heated head yellow
face herted light
or burning man crazy i'll give you those
again
it's very difficult what does gollum
call the sun does he call it heated head
yellow face hurted light
or that amazing ceremony in the desert
burning man
oh this is really testing me um
that's a tough one yeah i bet he only
says it once or twice in the books as
well yeah see i'm i'm trying to figure
out which
which like what would sound like he
would say because i have no idea to be
very honest try and channel andy circus
now
there you go that's very good i'm going
to say
did you say the heated sun is that one
thing no i'll give you them again ruby
you're almost bordering on cheating uh
the answers are heated head yellow face
hurted light or burning men and remember
you still have a foot
you still have a phone and a friend you
still have a phone a friend but if you
want i do
but if you want to go for it you you go
with your gut
i'm going to say herded light hurted
light is
not the right answer it's yellow
that's all right nicholas will trip up
on this necklace it's time to soar ahead
oh boy question number eight
how does farmer maggot keep unwanted
people
off his property does he use
poisonous mushrooms a murderous
scarecrow a pack of trained dogs
or tom bombadil
over to you nicholas for the answer
take your time no pressure that it's a
pack of trained dogs
final answer i think uh oh
yeah i'll i'll stick with it you're
absolutely right knuckles
it's fantastic you've soared ahead all
right now
here we go question nine reuben which
member
of the cast or crew had personally
met professor tolkien is it
ian mcelin oh mckellen i'm sorry
christopher lee peter jackson
or bernard hill
going to say christopher lee you sure
you don't want to
use me as a phone a friend you know
you're sure that's well yeah i wouldn't
let's phone you domino
dominic i'll have you take this one i i
think
well because i've heard him say i think
it's christopher lee
oh i would think so our producer is
telling us it is the correct
answer let's go well done
so we're at four reaches that correct is
that right you've got
you've got a question yeah we'll get one
in hand we'll get one in hand to win it
this to win it right
yes this is to win it which of
these are not a public
inn in the shire they are
not a public inn in the shire
the green dragon the branson pony
the old guest house the slaughtered
lamb
this for all the marbles and just so you
know there is a bag of mammals as a
surprise
well the prancing pony you guys went you
were a
frequent patron of so i'm not going to
pick that good good deduction
were we in the green dragon the green
dragon
the prancing pony the old guest house
and the slotted lamb the prancing pony
is in bree oh lovely bit of knowledge
there
but it's i'm my strong geographical
knowledge is a bit hazy i don't know
where the boundaries of the shire of
course you can ask william he sat
to my left you can ask him if you choose
to
um what were the other two again so
there is
four which of these is not a republican
in the show
the green dragon the prancing pony the
old guest house and the slotted lamb
i'm going to have to hurry up i might i
might ring you in
you're bringing me in right i think
that's a good idea
because i'm going to have to bring it up
again here with our producer john
because he's got there's one answer here
but i would say the prancing pony as you
said nicholas
is in bree and brie is not in the shire
john johnny
my dearest john oh oh yeah i don't mean
a publication
in middle earth john do you mean
and then anywhere in middle east
they're digging on google right now i
think we need some
fact checkers because at the end of the
show we will take you outside and
thrash you john to within an inch of
your life we're going to have to go at
another one nicholas because i think
they gave
i think that was a curveball as they say
in in america because i don't think the
prancing pony or the slaughtered lamb
is in well the slaughtered lamb
definitely isn't because that's from a
different movie yeah it's crazy
there's loaded lamps from a complete so
we're going to give you another one here
nicholas
so there is a bar called the slaughtered
lamb
from another movie is it from
an american werewolf in london game of
thrones
shadow and bone or the princess bride
inconceivable what movie
has the bar the slaughtered lamb
nicholas if you don't know this
seriously i'm going to hunt you down
come on wow this is a classic pub
hunt me down like ruben knows it looks
cuz that's going to be my answer
yeah what is that werewolf in london
nice work nicholas rubin unlucky i'm
sorry nicholas
there is obviously prizes as the dumb
yes we will be sending you a slaughtered
lamb uh in the next couple of weeks
in the mail enjoy that and a bag of
marbles and a bag of marbles
i heard that promise wonderful stuff
guys it's lovely to talk to you both
have a great rest of your day thank you
thank you on
sure that was great i apologize for our
producers
sorry about john we're going to be doing
that a lot see you guys
bye-bye bye thank you bye bye-bye
what a fantastic quiz yes it was dom
thanks ruben thanks nicholas if you'd
like to be one of the contestants how
did they get in touch
well you need to send us an email to
friendship onion
at cassmedia.com that's cast with a k
let us know that you want to be part of
the quiz and at some point they're not
doing a distant future we'll probably
have a prize
maybe a mug or a something there's got
to be
i mean a friendship onion something
a lapel badge a button a t-shirt
you never know what is it well that was
fun or maybe you'd like to quiz us
about something obviously com come like
hang out in our quiz but if you've got a
question for us
some deep dive into lord rings law that
you think i wonder if these guys even
know it
ask us you can email us friendship on
your castmedia.com
or you could send us a message
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion that's where you leave
a voice message for us
yeah and the email isn't their
friendship onion it's just
friendship onion at cast.com
cassmedia.com cass media me get a grip
just to clarify
[Music]
so here we go oh very exciting as we
look into
dom's diary now let's set the scene hang
on
christ i flipped it off my chair then
that was exciting
i get so excited i almost flew off my
chair it is exciting
right so there what's the date is there
a date ah did you put it today
did you learn nothing at school oh
that's a shame
yeah put a date at the top left yeah
there normally is a date
but there's none anyway can i make one
up
september yeah 24th september 24th so
here we go 1973.
i feel like i literally can't get
through
wetter and makeup this morning
i am in much need of sleep and nutrition
i sound like oscar wilde don't respect
it sounds like you're on desert island
carry on zombies just winced
at cold glue on my feet
doesn't hurt but it really [ __ ] goes
through me today look at the size of
that
look on an entire page i'm having a
nightmare okay oh here we go we turn the
page very good
so that was it so you're actually rating
that as you're getting your hobbit feet
oh i couldn't i was having a tough day
that's a day finished that was the day
finished i couldn't go anymore i
just couldn't i couldn't write anymore
that day which was the day that i've
just talked about i had an outrageous
migraine
felt sick horrible headache and we
conveniently we're in dodgy
stress positions hands and feet tied
but it was literally cured
by the beatles on the
i can't read my own writing on the
stereo
to pai kakariki what were we doing in
pai kakariki
that's a fantastic name of a place but i
can't actually remember where it was
so so i was having a tough time right we
dr we drove
to pi kakariki listening to the beatles
i felt much better
on the way there we saw
poo poo poo kakis
pokakis yeah new slateless
flightless like yes i think so
in the afternoon i killed the witch king
wow
that's a big deal isn't it so you would
have gone off and done something else
and i would have been with miranda
stabbing the witch king in the knee i
didn't even think i was there that day
when you
that was a big day for you i think that
was i think that was
on a set and then maybe we covered it
later on on location because i don't
think we were down in because wasn't
that twizzle when we were doing
the witch king anyway it's all it's all
documented here
uh in the afternoon i killed the witch
king yay and after
we did that i said to pete
that is the peak of my story and pete
jackson said
what like he thought i was wrapped
so he was confused but then i said
didn't you get me a cake or anything see
just forget all these things which made
everyone laugh
so we had a pretty big week the biggest
in terms of action
for mary did the palantir scene with
billy
oh yeah that was a good one yeah it was
that you grabbing hold of it
yeah sarah man's um
castle the flooding of the castle or do
you think that's in bed i think it's in
bed when i get up
and you say don't do it what you doing
sort of thing
right did the palantir stuff yeah yeah
meeting billy on the battlefield which
we
nailed oh that was it was great yeah and
then this is lovely
wow just two people who really like
and admire each other
talking in tupelo about how cool it is
to be working on such an amazing project
so we must have been in a great well
we're back and we're back in wellington
if we're in tupelo was uh was a
a bar if you'll remember it was a pub
and do you remember
when we first got to new zealand we
asked the locals what's a good bar and
they said tuple
and we walked around all night looking
for a bar called two pillows yeah we
even asked people
where do you know where two pillows is
no
no i do remember that
um what else is this uh spent the last
week
trying to get people to sign my book
lord rings book
oh is this near the end must be near the
end and all i have is john ruiz davis
and alan lee and peter jackson to do
surfed at castle point
and laughed and laughed with orlando and
tanya
at elijah so elijah did something funny
you may have told us what you did yeah
so that's dom's diary like i said we
can't do that every
week because i think it's way too hot i
think that's brilliant that dom
that was really enlightening and i
enjoyed it because for one thing
it told us that getting those hobbit
feet on
was was actually torture after a while
because you had to stand up right and as
you said it's not painful
but it's just something constantly
poking at your feet cold glue old
alcohol is cold five in the morning
maybe you've got a little cut on your
foots and then the alcohol goes into
your foot and it's
sharp and like you said it's not painful
so you can't
make a big deal out of it but it's the
fact that you're doing it every day
going through this rigmarole and i would
say what
three out of four times they wouldn't
see your feet so we'd be like really
guys
are you putting our feet on you know
they're only shooting close-ups it's
going to take us an hour and a half to
put them on
40 minutes to take them off and they're
like sorry we've been told
you never know the other thing because i
remember pete jackson
loving this the scene where
we're all asleep you wake up and you go
grab the palantir do you remember pete
jackson
loved the idea of us doing an
alternative take which was you with a
balloon
under your sheets so you had like a
massive swelling
and i would wake up and look over and go
what are you doing and you're like
yeah pete jackson he loves any of that
and he also in that scene as well
i did a little um a little nod
to harrison ford oh what was that in um
raiders of the lost ark when he takes
the golden
statue and he puts a bag of sand on it
when i took the palantir i said to pete
do you think it would be nice if i
grabbed the vase
and when i took the palantir i put the
vase in where um
gandalf was holding it and he went for
it and and gandalf is sleeping with his
eyes open which is brilliant because as
you go over you think oh i've been
caught here but then you realize that
you know he's a wizard so he sleeps with
his eyes oh yeah like a shark
very cool sweet well that was that that
was dom's diary dom's diary is
brilliant i hope we do that at least
once a month
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snail
guys as we said if you have a question
for myself or william boyd seated to my
left hello
you can send us that voicemail at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion
it could be about lord rings it could be
about anything it could just be a
question about life
you you're quite a philosopher in your
old age i tell you what i know a lot
about life
and i've forgotten more than you know
yeah that is true
so let's see what we've got this week
but um yeah
send us your questions the i think we
found out uh today that there's
8 000 voice messages that we're going to
do
right now if yeah if you want if you
want
a much higher chance of your question
being read out
make it a question that we've not been
asked before
and say it very loudly no don't say it
very loudly that wouldn't matter
yeah but send it to speakpipe.com
forward slash
the friendship onion and we'll do our
best to get through all the
questions with amazing answers all right
here we go question number one
we're listening here we go what's up
guys my name is uh nicolo i live
in virginia in the united states um
thanks so much for doing this podcast
really excited to
to see where it goes i really appreciate
all the work you both have put in over
the years and in lord of the rings and
your other projects as well um my
questions for both of you i'm just
curious what is your favorite
non-lord of the rings project that
you've worked on
i remember seeing dominic in flash
forward
back in the day when that was on tv and
really enjoyed him there of course lost
as well
i know flash forward never really gained
the traction of some of the other shows
but i always really enjoyed it so yeah
what was your
your favorite non-lord of the rings
project that you worked on whether it
was
tv movie music what have you
uh thanks so much guys and good luck
with the podcast
what a lovely question isn't it well you
know what
there's always something in every
project you know there's something that
maybe the town that it's in or there's
always something to enjoy you know
but i really loved mastering commander
because i loved being out on the tall
ships
and you know just sailing in the seas
and that whole
story was beautiful and if you remember
dom
i had a little um house down there
because they put us up
they put us up in a hotel and the hotel
was a golfing hotel
and i didn't play much golf at that time
but they used to
they used to water the the golf
the the fairways and the greens with
poo tainted water i don't know if you
remember
yeah so the place really smelled bad
so i asked if i could you know use the
money that the hotel would cost to get a
little house and i got a little house if
you remember
and everybody came to stay with me i
mean there was a point where it was
it was beyond a joke it was a because i
found a little house
that had a little wave in front of it
and everybody was
surfing at that time and you came down
and elijah
and two of the stunt men from louder
rings and people we used to surf with in
new zealand
oh sorry his wife it was your girlfriend
at the time it was like
15 people staying in a two-bedroom
everyone
yeah i think like you said probably 15
or so people just sleeping all over the
floor but what a
great experience because you would you
were going to work very often
but you'd created this kind of
environment of just hang out
surf i'm going to be at work until six
when i come back maybe i'll jump into
the ocean
but it kind of felt like a little bit of
a university frat house
yeah we had a little sort of hippie
commune going on down there i loved it
so that was a
that was a favorite one for me you had
very very cool hair back then do you
remember yeah you remember
long and you had big bushy sideburns and
you were suntan
but you kind of had like a like a bit of
a 1970s kind of rock star like a
creedence clear
i don't think i could do that now really
yeah it was it was good at the time they
never tell you about your hair like that
do you like like my hair is obviously
getting
thinner as i get older but like
the way that you style your hair then
becomes compromised by how your hair
wants to be like if i want my hair to go
crazy and be a bit wacky yeah probably
won't do that in the way that it used to
anymore because well not that much left
of it you put a picture up today on um
on
instagram and a friend of ours has
actually just commented on your hair oh
yeah
see if you can guess who would say this
about you someone has just said
what has happened to dom's hair i'm
going to start a gofundme
to get him a stylist is it nigel that
was nigel yeah he's always he
kicks me right where he works um
wait what oh oh favorite project um i
think my favorite project was
was my wildlife show oh wasn't that a
wonderful show
great because you know as you know as
you get older and older in the business
having a semblance of control over what
you're gonna do
and the artistic way that it's that it's
moving forward is helpful because then
every aspect of it is something that you
like so my wildlife show wild things
had my voice it was animals that i
wanted to
uh discover and work with it was places
around the world that i wanted to shine
a light on and everything about that
show
was me and also i love to travel i love
exotic food
i love crazy animals you came with me
really great to be able to do a show and
think oh i'm going to invite billy on
the show and they're like yeah invite
billy that would be great
and you introduced people to a lot of
animals they'd never have seen
yeah and i loved it i thought that was
bro i'm going to watch it tonight
there's a great moment with you and i
which i love one of my favorites where
we're in new zealand
and we're working with a reptile called
a tuatara and i had said to you so if
you're looking at this thing right now
what would you say is and you said well
i
think it was a lizard because it has a
face and a tail and a body and
everything that looks like a lizard
which is totally true but it's a
completely different type of reptile
it's not related to
uh lizards and snakes even though it
looks just like it
because it's evolved in a completely
different part of the world i just think
those
those moments in your life are
mind-blowing where you think well that
is something that i've seen before it
must be that and then someone says no
it's got nothing to do with that
incredible
atari incredible yeah beautiful
brilliant question
7999 to go
okay first of all um so pumped you guys
were doing this um i love your dynamics
so much
uh me and my best friend have been huge
fans here guys
since like fifth grade um so for years
now
um and i just wanted to ask you guys
um what is your favorite comedy movie
and why
it's a great question we didn't find
very good young lady's name
unfortunately no we didn't but she
sounded like she had a really good mic
or something maybe she wants to be
anonymous
right right okay um
favorite comedy movie probably this is
spinal tap for me
i mean yeah 90 minutes just from my own
personal preference there's not a film
that is an hour and a half long that
makes me laugh
more and the relationship between the
lead singer and the lead guitarist is
absolutely adorable so if you've never
seen this spinal tap
check it out i would say
it's not one movie and i could probably
pick one if i had to
but the pink panther movies with peter
sellers
maybe the return of the pink panther or
a shot in the dark
i love those films guy was a genius
brilliant
there's an incredible moment in a shot
in the dark where where he shows up to
view the murder scene my favorite and
the guy says to
uh cluso would you like to see the body
and he says i would be delighted
he just has some brilliant brilliant
moments there's been another globe thing
the pavlova of the parallel bars
yeah i'm going to see a shot in the dark
yeah shot in the dark it's brilliant
i'm going to watch that tonight as well
i've got a lot to do tonight
right next one keep them coming
hello billy and dom hello my name is
mary
i am a huge fan obviously i love the
lord of the rings you guys are my
favorite hobbits
um i love lost i love master and
commander i love bee cake
blah blah blah anyway speaking of bee
cake
um segue i was calling to see
if you guys could talk music what your
favorite all-time musicians are what
you've been jamming to
lately whatever you like i don't care
i'm just excited for the podcast
and i thought that would be a good topic
if you haven't already discussed it or
have been
asked anyway thank you so much love you
bye bye oh man lovely now was it mary or
was it mary
so here's the thing either way we won't
know well i think it's
m a r y which in
the united states of america most people
pronounce
like your name and lord of rings
m-e-r-r-y
yeah mary and mary are pronounced the
same way in the united states
which i think was confusing for people
when lord of the rings came out yeah
that they were like oh is his name mary
as in mary a lot of people will refer to
me as
mary in the united states oh you played
mary right now i'm not a girl's name
yeah but that's all right but yeah so
that's confusing
and tolkien should have really taken
that on board well
one of the one of the things about
tolkien's work that that
is a little challenging but you just
have to get through it is
he purposefully has characters
that have names relatively similar right
yeah boromir pharami er
irwin saruman sauron he's looking for a
mirror yeah
yeah characters if you're not kind of
concentrating on those books
you can sometimes go wait which which is
that yeah i've got to go back a couple
of pages
i don't want to criticize one of the
greatest books of all time but come on
yeah you know what i mean like
it should be zebedee yeah yeah and then
you would go
yeah i know who that is so music you're
the musician
out the two of us well see right well
music lots
lots and lots i was thinking though
because someone asked me to go into
their music podcast
about favorite albums and things and i
was thinking about the classics
and then i thought you know what let's
think in the last 10 years
what do i listen to more than anything
else and it would be an album by
king creosote called the the diamond
mind diamond mine
sorry and uh i'll listen to that album
more than any other even now so
i have to say that that's one of the
greatest albums otherwise
why would they listen to it
recommendation because i don't think
that many people have their eyes on king
crews so dude yeah so i would say
listen to king creosote and listen to in
particular
the diamond mine do you find
like a lot of people who
live the same cliched kind of
uh ideas with music as everyone else
that you kind of get stuck
in a way with the music that was
influential
in your late teens to early 20s do you
know what i mean
you i think so and then it's there's so
much music out there but it's hard to
get introduced to the stuff that's not
in the mainstream
i just read a um a quote from and i
forget his name
maybe the most famous japanese
uh writer of novels alive today
is it mirazaki it might be and he said
he said you know if you read the same
books as everyone else
you'll have the same ideas as everyone
else and i feel that way
in any art yeah right yeah so music you
do have to try and
scrape your way out of the middle
sometimes
just to see what else is going on yeah
well you know who i'm gonna start
to kind of delve into their back
catalogue because
i know that lennon and mccartney rated
him
highly and he is a real blind spot
in my musical knowledge is frank zappa
uh yeah i like his work yeah the little
bits that i've heard and he's crazy and
mad cap
but honestly i couldn't name an album no
well why don't we both do that
and we'll talk about that let's do that
sometime in the near future
if you guys want to ask us to listen to
an album that for you guys has been
incredibly influential or something
that's changed your life or a song
that's got you through a tough time
maybe it's some of billy's music maybe
it's the lesser known music that i've
never released
let's get in touch with us i'll tell you
what i'm into
at the moment go they're not necessarily
new or anything but i'm really enjoying
their back catalogue is
the 1975. oh yeah you like that you said
to me
a while ago i think they're great yeah
you do you really like them
nice kind of upbeat summer jams
great videos good design i think for
some reason
they went very big and popular and that
ultimately makes them slide down
the other side of people being a bit
passive okay but i think the music's
great
you would know this more than me but
music has dramatically changed over the
last decade right like no one's buying
albums anymore right it's all
singles no one's really making money
like they're used to making music
yes crazy huh um
i won't mention names but i've got a
friend who's in a popular band
and he said now when they're working out
making
a new album music they have to do it
by financially saying we won't make any
money
from the actual selling of the album wow
and he says you know he remembers the
90s when
you know that's all the money came from
selling the album and then you go on
tour
just to sell the album now they go on
tour to sell t-shirts and
you know to make a living because they
don't make
any money from the music crazy crazy
beautiful okay is there another question
that's
it out of the 7 000 questions only three
of them were worthwhile
that's amazing people you need to do
better
send better questions to speakpipe.com
forward slash
the friendship onion thanks friends
so throughout last year with us all
going through this
covid corona time you were obviously
with your wife and son but i spent
probably january till august on my own
in my house wow and i remember reaching
out to you saying hey bill
i've picked up this game online which is
free to play
free to download and it means that if
you were to play it with me we would
have that little
interaction because it's like getting on
the phone because you can talk to you
you can chat to each other
the game's called league of legends
it's a moba do you know a moba is
m-o-b-a
mobile outside broadcast
oblivious four out of four wrong there
and oblivious does not start with an
a oh what did you say yeah moba
no i don't know i don't know what it
means multiplayer online
battle yeah arena that's what it is
is it so you you tell people at home
like what is what what's league of
legends right for anyone that doesn't
know league of legends
you you you choose a warrior
a champion if you will and then you
and four other champions go into a map
that's always the same and it's kind of
like catch the flag
because you've got to get to the other
person's base station
and blow up their flag thing well
well they're all trying to get to yours
and blow up your flag thing
nexus but the champion that you have
will have
certain amounts of powers activated by
the letters
q w e and r yeah so it sounds very very
simple you have a champion
they have special abilities only four
special abilities but there's about 150
champions
and you have to pick who you kind of
prefer so at the moment
you're rocking on a guy called dr mundo
what's dr mundo's deal
dr mundo is a jungler so he doesn't hang
around with other people
he goes in the jungle and destroys
creatures and becomes
super strong and then helps out everyone
else in his team
and dr mundo's kind of super power is
that he can
absorb a huge amount of damage because
it actually
heals him when he takes damage is that
right kind of
but if you're not very good at dr mundo
which i am not people in the team
when it's not you or one of our friends
will tell me that i'm rubbish
yeah there's a thing called flaming in
league of legends
and that's when you kind of shout and
scream at people and billy and i have
been in games where people have said you
two
are the worst players of this champion
we've ever seen
thanks very much somebody said to me the
other day please don't play again
yeah i've had someone say delete the
game i'm like oh come on guys it's just
a game we're just trying to chat to each
other and have a nice time but what's
interesting about league of legends and
if you've not played it
they don't sponsor the show they've got
nothing to do with the show we just
really like playing it
when it's bad when you've finished a
game where you've been absolutely
destroyed and demoralized
it's a kind of two out of ten but when
it's good it's a good
10 out of 10 isn't it when we they're
doing a game just now where everyone's
the same character
and we all played dr mundo one for all
dr mundo
and we had a great time brilliant so the
reason why we're telling you about
league of legends is
there's a pretty strong chance that in
the upcoming shows
billy and i might have little mentions
of league of legends here and there so
if you want to follow along
with some of the jargon that we're going
to use playing league of legends
download the game it's free
play the game and then tell us about
your stories about people shouting at
you telling you to delete the game as
well so that we don't feel as bad
and if you join the game bring a
positivity to it yeah we are going to
make it a game where everyone says
well done yeah or if you're not playing
too good that's a shame
yeah yeah right john well is that it
it's almost but i did want to tell you i
went to physio yesterday
because i've hurt my knees slightly from
jumping too high
but you hurt your knee years ago that
was that nice oh it's a different name
yeah
so that knee is knackered that knee is
an awful knee
but it's still you know it'll take me
around in the place
but this one has now started something
so i went to the physio and he basically
says what's wrong
is whenever i'm doing anything i'm not
activating my butt
enough right so if you don't mind me
saying you've got quite a small
posterior
incredibles if i wear any pants without
a belt
they will fall down right even the
correct size get your squats in
yeah we did squats and what i have to do
is activate my butt more
even in squats i'll activate my thighs
which are very strong
i can kick a soccer ball tremendous
distances but i need to activate my butt
more so i'll be working on that in the
next few weeks if there's anyone out
there that would like to encourage billy
to activate his
bot more um just send us an email um
friendship onion at castmedia.com or if
you want to be involved in the quiz
we've told you this before but you can
send us an email there
or you can send us a message at
speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion if
you have
if you have enjoyed the show please rate
review
and subscribe here's the thing guys
right if you're enjoying the show
you want to subscribe so that you don't
have to keep looking for us every week
it just
turns up on your phone the other thing
that you might not know about and we're
here to tell you is
if you rate and reviewers it pushes us
up
further in the chart means that we can
do this show longer
we can dish the dirt a little bit more
about life
in general tell your secrets about lord
of the rings everyone's happy
so get involved get in touch with us
we'll see you next week
yeah see you next week on the friendship
onion bring us in another can of
bundaberg
uh john and we will get absolutely
wrecked